Pirates had infected the seas for generations
So I vowed to eliminate them all
And then there was this boy
Jack Sparrow
Follow him in
He took everything from me
and filled me with
Rage
The dead have taken command of the sea
They are searching for a Pearl
A Girl
and a Sparrow
I've heard stories
of a mighty Spanish Captain
who's hunted and killed
thousands of men
No, no, no, man, no
No, no, no, no
Pirates
I once knew a Spaniard named something in Spanish
He is coming for you Jack
Where is your Ship?
Your crew?
Your pants?
Jack
I am so sorry. Were you still talking?
There is nowhere to hide
Find Sparrow for me
From this moment on we have to be allies
Considering where your left hand is I'd say we are more than that
Ahh, Monkey
I'm not looking for trouble
What a horrible way to live
You will pay for what you did to me
Men on that ship are looking for Jack
so I am going to swim for it
Carina, Stop this
No, no, no, no, no, don't stop it
This is gone far enough
No, it has not
I saw her ankles
You'd have seen a lot more if you'd kept your cakehole shut